please welcome the last king of
Scotland's personal physician and one of
the movie year's most beguiling
illusions James McAvoy and Jessica Biel
in 1927 in the picture that changed it
all the jazz singer the great Al Jolson
said you ain't heard nothing yet and we
still haven't heard the end of it
but we've heard everything else thanks
to the work of the Wizards at the sound
board the mixers here are the nominees
for sound mixing Kevin O'Connell Greg
pedroso
and Fernando camera for Apocalypto Andy
Nelson Annabel MA and Ivan Chirac for
Blood Diamond
Michael Minkler Bob BEMER and Willie
button for Dreamgirls John writes Dave
Campbell Gregg brutal off and waltz
Martin for Flags of Our Fathers Paul
Massey christopher boys and lee Orloff
for Pirates of the Caribbean Dead Man's
Chest and the Oscar goes to Michael
Minkler Bob BEMER and Willie Burton for
Dreamgirls
Michael Miller's son Chris was recording
mixer on Babel the family has four
generations of sound mixers this is
third Academy Award and tenth nomination
the fourth Oscar win for Bob BEMER and
the second win for Willie Burton
they both had seven nominations
there's no way I'm gonna be able to do
this by memory so first of all we
congratulate Bill Condon thank you so
much you crafted a film that was filled
with dazzling performances unforgettable
songs from Henry Krieger stylish effects
from Richard young electrifying editing
from Virginia cats and some smokin sound
in the end you think this for helping
you make your dream it's really the
other way around
Bob Willie and I were so honored by this
award and we thank all of those who sell
collaborated with us on the mix and we
extend our love and appreciation to
those in our family who bring us harmony
in our lives like if they got producing
team I will cast and crew also my lovely
wife Jackie for her support and mom
thank you god bless you all
I think that I like think Cindy Jessie
Amy LG